We asked our audience
three true or false financial questions,
and you're going to help us unlock the correct answer.
First, true or false?
When cutting back on spending,
should you start with streaming service subscriptions
and apps that incur monthly fees?
Okay, so our poll revealed
that 61% of the audience said this is true.
Sounds kind of rational.
What is the answer?
So this one I'm gonna say false on.
Really, why?
And I'll give you
a reason why.
Is because it is easy to cut on Netflix.
It's the easy, low-hanging fruit.
But it's gonna save you maybe $15 per month.
And that's not really gonna move the needle
as much as you might think when saving or trying to save.
So what I encourage people to do
is start with the big three, your three biggest expenses.
That's housing, transportation and food.
So if you start with the big three,
that's how you actually save much more in the long term.
So, for example, if you're living in a studio apartment,
like you're renting an apartment,
if you get a roommate,
you can actually save five to $600 per month
just by getting a roommate.
Or what's also becoming popular,
if you own a home, you can rent out a room
to a friend or family member
and they can help pay for your mortgage.
So doing that, you're actually saving
hundreds of dollars per month.
That's gonna move the needle much more
than just cutting on $15 Netflix.
That is the kind of wisdom you're like,
"Oh, $15 a month won't move the needle."
"Hundreds of dollars a month, needle mover," I love this.
Okay, so tangible, next, true or false?
You should charge smaller expenses
and your services to your credit card instead of debit card.
I loved this question.
Our poll revealed 44% of the audience said that was true.
John, what is the real answer?
I would say true on this one.
Okay, good.
Yes, yes, so that's good.
The reason you want to put
smaller expenses on your credit card
is because if you're maxing out
your credit card every single month,
that's actually gonna hurt your credit score.
And so we wanna put the small expenses on it.
Like maybe gas, groceries,
things you can pay off in full every single month.
So I always recommend putting small expenses,
recurring expenses, on your credit card.
You can pay it off in full every month,
you'll build a good credit score,
and you'll never go into credit card debt.
I love that, thank you.
Yeah.
That is so, so helpful.
Small expenses.
Okay, last one, true or false?
The best way to divide your monthly income
is equally 33% for your needs, then wants, then savings.
Our audience, 46% said,
"Yeah, that sounds like a good approach."
John, what is a good approach?
So in an ideal world, 33% for your needs,
33% for your wants, 33% for your savings.
But that's maybe not realistic.
In the personal finance community,
we like to go with the 50/30/20 rule.
So 50% for your needs,
that's housing, maybe childcare, things like that.
30% for your wants,
that's vacations, maybe going out, things like that.
And then, 20% for saving and investing.
So that is much more realistic.
And I promise if you're saving and investing
20% of your income,
you will become wealthy over time.
And just like as a side note,
like what do you think are good things
to look out for, investment wise, for people?
Yeah, I think investment wise,
and it definitely depends on your situation each time,
but real estate is always
gonna stand the test of time, right?
Buying and owning your own home
is always going to be a good idea.
And then, when it's investing in maybe stocks,
I always recommend an index fund,
which an index fund is like a gift basket full of stocks.
So it's like you can own Tesla,
Google, Facebook, Microsoft,
like a bunch of different stocks together
in one nicely-packaged gift basket.
And we know those companies are not going
anywhere anytime soon.
Yes.
Those sound very safe.
That's right, exactly.
Exactly, it's safe and you can grow your money that way.
I love that, thank you, I so appreciate that.
John Eringman, thank you so much for coming on.
Thank you.
Long-time fan,
first-time caller.
Follow him on TikTok for more
of his awesome financial tips and tricks!
(upbeat music)